[Music]
the rain was pouring hard that day in
Brooklyn it was my first day at PS 203
teaching extracurricular courses 200
loud and rambunctious kiddies ran into
the cafeteria and I tried to settle them
down but they were too excited to begin
the new year but one little girl named
Alicia didn't look excited at all in
fact she was in tears I walked over to
Alicia and I asked her what was wrong
can't you see it she answered sobbing
it's so obvious it wasn't obvious to me
so I asked her again my hair misdoing
it's my hair this morning it was nice
and straight when my mom fixed it and as
soon as I got outside in that rain poof
my afro came right back and now all the
boys are making fun of me for it I told
Alicia her hair was beautiful but it
didn't work he dismissed me with a yeah
whatever it's your job to say that I
write multicultural children's books and
when I first decided to write these
books I did it for girls like Alicia I
wanted them to have books I didn't have
growing up books that highlight girls
who look like her and have hair like
hers because representation matters but
in the process of creating these books I
learned something profound it is a
beautiful thing when we can see
ourselves in the stories of people like
us but it is a powerful thing when we
can see ourselves in the stories of
people unlike us now I know many of us
in this room would probably consider
ourselves just a little bit older than
my target readership but I've learned by
that by exploring diverse narratives
such as the ones I write about we get
that powerful thing the unique
to unravel the similarities that can
bridge all of our differences it all
started in the exploratory phase of my
creative writing process I did extensive
research on all the cultures I wanted to
write about
I watched very long educational
documentaries I read very dense
informative texts on the tenets of
culturally relevant pedagogy but it
wasn't enough something was missing
writing for children is a funny
experience you see I went to PS 203 so I
could learn how they learn
I wanted to observe how they would
engage with this kind of content I
wanted to teach them about people and
places so that they could be curious
about our diverse planet but what I
discovered was this although I knew it
was very important for them to grow up
understanding these concepts they didn't
know that and they didn't have to know
that because when you're five six seven
years old all you want when you pick up
a book is a real good story and that was
it at the core of my multicultural
educational exposure mission I needed to
harness the power of the story so I
picked up my research process again this
time I interviewed as many people as I
could find from those cultures and those
countries and I just listened to their
stories I took note of every little
detail they shared especially the ones
their faces lit up about like when I was
creating shizzle my girl character from
Trinidad and Tobago
I interviewed a family of Trinidadian
immigrants and they told me about the
tree that they had in their backyard
when they were growing up in the
countryside which is different from the
kind of tree that you would see if you
only visit the city with all the rest of
the tourists and they chuckled about how
they would play with their siblings
underneath that tree and shake it to all
the coconuts fell down a seemingly
insignificant detail at first glance
maybe but it is in those details that I
instantly felt connected to someone I
thought was so different I may not have
grown up in Trinidad but growing up in a
suburban part of Brooklyn also with an
immigrant family
I knew all about playing with my
siblings underneath big trees and is
upon those little details and those
little connections that I built an
entire book and for every book I wrote I
listened to dozens more of these stories
and from India to Colombia I found
myself in each of their narratives this
enabled my writing to go beyond any fact
or any figure that I could find online
or in a text book or even in my own
personal travel experiences to those
countries most of all it gave me that
skill that can be applied to anyone in
this room I learned how to relate with
people who do not look like me to hear
them to understand them to work with
them but maybe you're not planning on
writing or reading multicultural
children's books anytime soon
how can you harness the power of the
story to build your own empathy bridge
you can start by reading a book any book
fact or fiction about someone from
another part of the world enter their
journey as though it were yours see just
how different or similar the world is
from their eyes but what I love about
the power of the story is that it's not
just on the pages of a book
it's everywhere we just have to
recognize and appreciate when we see it
but maybe that means you'll finally sit
down with that classmate or that
co-worker that you pass by every day you
exchange a routine hi how you doing I'm
fine
you see them sure but do you know their
story or it could be something as simple
as watching a film from a foreign
country in another language and seeing
how it resonates with you my personal
favorite Korean dramas I love Korean
dramas I'm not ashamed perhaps none of
these concepts are new to you it's no
surprise in the polarized world we live
in today that there is indeed an empathy
gap across our communities that we need
to bridge why aren't we bridging it here
we are afraid to move away from what is
familiar think about the people you
surround yourself with all the time do
you constantly find yourself in the
comfort zone of a homogeneous creed
class color fill in the blank these safe
spaces are important but the problem is
it's often where the least growth
happens but if we can embrace the
vulnerability that comes with sharing
our stories and the courage needed to
seek out the stories of others we can
build empathy for our peers we can
shatter misconceptions one by one we can
better understand each other better
understand how to serve each other we
can heighten our awareness of those that
are right around us that we ignore every
single day halfway through that
extracurricular course at PS 203 I laid
out the final character developments of
my premier collection of children's
books before my esteemed panel of fourth
graders one of them being Alicia I like
her Alicia pointed to a quia my gun and
girl character and she pointed
emphatically so I was intrigued I asked
Alicia what she liked most about a quia
I like her hair
Alicia responded its foxy
I laughed trying to remind Alesha of the
crying incident that had happened just a
few weeks earlier but at least she said
she had no recollection whatsoever she
had just finished reading all about
aqueous journey from Cape Coast to our
cry and spell felt especially connected
to the books references on art and
friendship but when I asked Alesha why
she loved aqueous so much she said
something very simple it's because I am
she and she is me
I pressed arguing that she had never
even heard of Ghana prior to that day
and many of the cultural references in
that book were brand new to her but she
insisted
it doesn't matter miss doing I am she
and she is me so whenever I get tempted
to revert to what is comfortable to
those who are familiar I remember the
words of Alicia I restate them to myself
back to the world that I am they and
they are me thank you
[Applause]
[Music]